what's exciting for us when we enter the
motion capture lab is we have the
opportunity to take a device or
technology of therapy and actually test
it on human subjects
impact for us starts with human data and
that's the data we hope to gather here
in the motion capture lab my research is
translational research my focus has been
primarily on infants and toddlers
developing synthetic muscles called the
second skin and we've gotten many
insights into the design of these
muscles by using the motion capture lab
to see how we might place them what size
they should be how much force or torque
they should generate we're designing
software well robots to assist with
walking the nice thing about the motion
capture lab is that it provides a great
resource for helping to understand how
humans walk very efficiently or had
patients with disabilities are not able
to walk really to understand human
performance we need to take an
experimental approach so we use the
motion capture lab to be able to record
biomechanical and physiological data
we can bring to bear a variety of
sensors from muscle activity sensors to
accelerometers to measure limb motion to
motion capture with the marker system
even oxygen consumption
stochastic resonance is a sensory
enhancement technology that improves
balance and performance by vibrating
below perceptible levels
so it's basically getting neurons to
fire without causing them to fire we are
incorporating this technology into
medical devices including a vibrating
shoe insert to sensitize neurons in
so the motion capture lab is reading an
invaluable and critical research tool
and without it we really wouldn't be
able to know the effect of these systems
on human performance the engineering
cycle requires rapid turnaround
redesigning prototypes through many
iterations and the amazing feature of
the motion capture lab is that we can go
into the laboratory conduct studies and
then modify the devices in relatively
short period of time in a traditional
institution that would be involved with
device design and testing you would
actually build the device and then
contract with an outside service for
agency to actually do that testing what
the motion capture lab allows us to do
is to accelerate that early testing
rates because we can build test and
evaluate on human subjects we can do
that in a single lab and we can do that
here
that's the only way to really gain an
understanding if our designs and control
strategies are moving in the right
direction so it helps us fail sooner and
it also helps us succeed sooner
you